hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
a property investor and this week
i'm going to be answering all of the
personal questions that you've been
asking me
about my property portfolio and about
what i'm personally doing
right now in this property market now if
you've got questions about
property about finance entrepreneurship
ask below because i do read your
questions and i do answer them every
single sunday
and i don't normally you know what
people ask me a lot of questions
sometimes about me
you know samuel what are you doing here
and what's this and what's that and i
don't know sometimes whether
whether the people asking the questions
are just curious
or whether they're wanting to know the
answers from a learning perspective
so i don't know exactly why but i just
figured well why not just answer some of
the more personal questions
and listen i'm very very i'm always open
about what i'm doing
but don't forget just because i'm doing
something doesn't mean that you should
be doing it
what where i've got to i've been in
property now for over a decade
my strategy has developed has snowballed
has advanced
i've got a lot of full-time staff some
of my staff are on six figures
on the property business so my setup now
is very very different to my setup when
i was
19 20 when i was 23 when i was 25
now i'm 29 it's it's advanced it's
changed
so sometimes people get a little bit
like what are you doing why are you
what's happening it's because i'm
advanced
okay so by the way if you like my
youtube channel please do smash the like
button please do subscribe turn the
notification bell on let's get some of
these questions number one is
people are freaking out because they're
saying samuel why are you selling
some of your houses right now and the
reason i'm selling some of my houses
right now is because i'm using
the money from these smaller houses to
put into
other houses i'm not selling up my
property portfolio
i'm not saying oh i'm done with property
like in the slightest it's really funny
because if i say if i if i'm if i say to
people
hey everyone i'm buying i'm buying i'm
buying i'm buying and i'm showing people
what i'm buying everyone goes
that's interesting cool but then as soon
as i sell three four houses people are
freaking out somebody was selling some
houses
but i'm selling houses to buy houses
so it's it's really not odd it's not it
shouldn't
it shouldn't strike you as strange for a
property investor
for a property entrepreneur that trades
buys
flips a lot of houses to sometimes sell
houses like
like i've just built a bunch of houses
and i'm selling them i'm selling some
new builds at the moment
that's not weird so some of the houses
that i bought a few years back i'm now
selling it's not weird it's a normal
thing to happen
in the life of a property investor so
why am i selling houses
i'm selling houses to release cash to
put into
other bigger projects next why not just
refinance because it depends
per property per situation i do
refinance houses sometimes in fact often
i'll refinance i'll buy a house
it will go up in value i'll refinance or
reinvest
when i met lord sugar and i had business
advice when i had my mentoring session
from lord sugar one of the things lord
sugar told me because i i said to me
what's your goal
what's the big term plan and i told him
i wanted a thousand houses you know what
he said to me
he said that's a stupid goal why would
you want one earth this is what he said
why on earth would you want to do that
and at the time i didn't get why he said
that
at the time i'm thinking he's a
billionaire property investor
he's very very successful and i'm
telling him i want a thousand houses i
thought he'd applaud
me but he didn't this has a stupid plan
why because in 2017
maybe it was about three years ago when
i met lord sugar i
didn't get it i didn't get it
here's what i did get i was a
millionaire when i met lord sugar so i
wasn't doing too bad
now i'm a multi-millionaire but i didn't
get it when i started out in property
all i wanted was 2 000 pounds a month
passive income
and then i got that i'm like great i'm
making two thousand pound a month
then i wanted six thousand pound a month
got it then i wanted to become a
millionaire
got it and and and what happens is you
start growing and
your goals change your perspectives
change
so i'm there saying to lord sugar i want
a thousand houses and he he's just like
what for
why do you want a thousand houses and
i'm like
because it's got a nice ring to it and
it sounds impressive
how shallow how ridiculous it's not
about how many houses you own
you don't want to necessarily just have
a really i know people that have got
over 100 houses
and they're not making any money on
those houses
it's not about how many houses you own
it's about how much
money you're making it's about how
strategically set up your portfolio is
so lord joe gave me some really really
good advice i'm gonna probably do a
whole video about the lord sugar
um incident and the advice i got i have
written a blog about it i've written an
article i'll leave that in the
description below and you can check out
the article so
why not refinance because it because i
might because i might not necessarily
want to refinance it
i might want to sell it i'll do both it
just depends there's no black and white
cat all right here's an interesting one
that's come on people have been
asking me almost in a slightly
accusational way at times
okay and i'm gonna clear this up they've
been saying
that i am a a hypocrite might be a bit
of a strong word but they've been saying
samuel
why do you tell people to
finance properties to get mortgages to
leverage money
when you yourself have been buying
loads of houses for cash why do you buy
loads of properties for cash
why do you pay off mortgages but then
you tell us and you tell on your youtube
channel
to not do that and it's a very fair
question and i'm going to give you a
very
um solid explanation so firstly i want
to say
right now i don't buy houses for cash i
went through a stage okay
like 2018 2019 what happened was my
properties went so high up in value and
i i refinanced a few
and i had so much cash i was making so
much money and i never
i never expected to make loads of money
and and
i don't teach people how to make
millions of pounds that to be honest
that's kind of not what i'm about what
i'm about
is being financially independent it's
about being able to
escape a job that you don't like and be
able to provide for yourself and have
more time that's kind of what my message
is
but i became so engrossed in property i
became so engrossed in business
and i absolutely and i started making a
lot of money
and i became a millionaire at 25 but
then 26 27 i became a multi-millionaire
and what happened was when i started
getting loads of money and my properties
really were doing well every aspect of
my business was doing well
and i just thought wow i don't know what
to do with all this money it's crazy i
didn't know if i wanted to just
absolutely explode so i started paying
off mortgages i had so much money i was
just buying properties in cash
you probably remember this stage if
you've been following me on youtube for
a long time you probably remember when
about 18 months ago
i was just giving people money you've
probably seen it on youtube well i'm
like i'll write the check and i even i
even set up like a bridging company
where i was just giving people money and
you can see it on youtube
i was just saying you want half a
million quid here's a check bang
that was me 18 months ago you want to do
a pr i couldn't be bothered to do the
projects i couldn't even be bothered i'm
embarrassed to say now i know it makes
me like a jerk but i'm just being really
honest
i was sometimes when i was buying little
houses i was too
complacent to even bother filling out
the paperwork on the mortgage
application just bite for cash
that that's how i got and as a result of
that
i didn't have any mentors because all of
my mentors
had outgrown all of my mentors i was
making more money than them
the people that had worked with me
supported me training i'm making more
money
and i did get a little bit lost i got a
bit lost
i knew how to teach someone to become
financially free believe me i knew how
to do that
i even missed the days of becoming
financially free that's why i started
doing the financial freedom challenges
because i was thinking i just want to
start again and hustle i didn't like
having all this
cash and all this and it was just like
man
you know and that is that was that was
where i was at i mean january 2019
i was just giving out money i was just
funding
projects and saying just give me 15 roi
i don't care just have the money have
the money
as long as i got a charge on the
property and that was what i was doing
and
and i felt a bit lost and i went
to some very senior business advisors
and met them and one of the people that
i met and i paid a lot of money to do
this as well
one of the people that i paid a lot of
money to meet was grant cardone
and grant cardone was the first person
that could actually kind of relate to me
because grant cardone has also done very
well grant cardone's
i think he's a billionaire if he's not a
billionaire he might be close he's worth
hundreds of millions
hundreds of millions and when i met
grant cardone
he was in better physical shape than i
was at the time i'm coming for you grant
but he was in better physical shape
he was a lot wealthier he wasn't lost he
had it together
he had a clear plan and he just said to
me
what are you doing what why are you
giving loads of people money
and asking for a fixed return why are
you paying off all these
what what are you doing and this was in
july 2019
and he really really gave me focus again
and you know what he told me the thing
that really really did it for me
he said the way that you're acting right
now is someone who's an
old retired rich man who's over the hill
who's not got any goals left that's how
you're acting and when
grant cardone who's in his 60s he's in
better physical shape than me
who's way richer than me says
you're over the hill and at the time i
was 28
i just completely changed my strategy
and
that's when i decided that some of the
little smaller deals i'm going to put
into bigger deals
i'm going to stop buying properties for
cash anymore i'm not going to do that
i'm going to be smart with my money
because this is the best way to do it
and i just changed my strategy
and so so yeah i did go through a phase
and i'm not embarrassed to admit it i
mean geez i was doing well
i was doing really well and i am doing
really well but i was going through a
phase where i was just buying stuff in
cash
throwing out cash i was also um
i was losing focus a little bit of my
personal business goals
so grant really helped me with that and
so did many other people many other
mentors
and that was what i learned that you
always need to be continually finding
someone's doing better than you are
and asking them to give you perspective
so thanks grant and and that's that's
why so hopefully that explains because
yeah for sure you can find videos of me
saying to people don't buy a property
for cash
use a mortgage it's smarter but then
also find videos of me going i just
bought a house for cash
and and i get why some people might be
like what happened there but that's
that's why i did that that
hopefully that explains it and i'm not
perfect i'm figuring things out
i'm 29 i'm from a pr a background
a working class background where i
didn't i didn't learn anything in school
about property i
wasn't i'm not from a from a family
history of property investors or
business people
my mom's a mobile hairdresser my dad
entertainer gardener
now does on the network marketing
business like oh i'm you know i'm
figuring things out i'm learning
and it's great to learn off of you folks
as well and it's great to be able to
teach you and i'm not
i'm not ever standing here saying i know
everything there is to know about
investment and property and i'm the
absolute
you know no i'm learning what i'm really
good at is i'm really good
my forte is starting from scratch and
becoming financially free
that's what i'm really good at that's
why i do the financial freedom
challenges that's what i did that's what
i teach
i had to learn how to manage millions of
pounds
and i'm still learning that and i've got
a long way to go but i'm getting really
good
and i'm really excited about my next 10
years and for those by the way for those
people that have just stood with me
for my whole journey because you've seen
me grow you saw me start
from 25 years old when i was when i was
doing when i was okay fine i was doing
well but you saw me
there and you you've seen me grow over
the years and i'm going to grow a lot
over the next 10 years as well so thanks
for your support and thanks for your
help on that
all right next why auction why am i
selling from auction because it's fast
i i've i've personally seen how long and
slow and laborious it can be to sell a
house
when people pull out and then this and
that auctions fast and also it's a myth
that auction properties always sell
really cheap actually auction properties
sometimes sell for more expensive than
with a high street agent so
i like selling from auction because time
is money not always isn't the best but
even if you end up selling it 10 15
grand less just for the speed
and for the and for the assurance for me
it's worth it because time is freaking
money
is it a good time to sell probably not
probably not a great time to sell
i just sold three houses uh earlier this
week
and you know what i wasn't happy with
the price that i got
i was happy that i sold them but they
just barely hit the reserve price and
that was annoying
but we are living right now in a very
time which is a
right now it's a buyer's market it's not
sellers market i'm a buyer right now
i'm buying right now but i'm selling to
buy as well so
the sales side yeah it's not a great
time to sell but if you
if you're selling because you're going
to be buying something and you want to
sell this to buy this
maybe take the hit on this to then take
the big hit on this but you're the buyer
here
but yeah i'm not particularly loving the
prices that i'm getting i can't lie
why i'll ask the question why do i give
addresses people some people are saying
to me samuel can't you just show your
title deeds for all of your houses and
then suddenly we'd all be assured that
you're
listen that's that's stupid i i don't
even think people that say that people
say can you please
tell me you'll prove that you own all
these houses it's like firstly i don't
need to prove anything
to anybody i don't need to prove that
i've got i don't need to prove that i'm
a multi-multi-millionaire
i mean anyone that knows anything about
business that can look into it can
probably see that it's true
you've seen on youtube you've heard from
my solicitors but
and another thing is if i give out all
the addresses to all of my properties
with the title deeds all that's going to
happen is my tenants are going to start
getting harassed and
i make a deliberate choice that i'm
happy me
to be in the public spotlight and the
newspaper is constantly right about me
sometimes good sometimes bad i i put
myself out there
but just because i choose to put myself
out there i don't think that necessarily
means that i need to then
make sure put all my tenants out there
and put all my
you know that that's that's them that's
their homes
this is me so for me to for me to put
out all my
addresses of my properties just to prove
something to people that are like
oh does he really own the houses that he
says
it would just be it's just stupid so
i mean listen i'll put stuff out there
for sure i will i have put stuff out
there i'll show i'll vlog myself doing
deals
i've had my solicitor confirm different
things
absolutely but anyone that's that
obsessed
with so desperately wanting to know
figure out all the addresses all my
houses i would just say probably better
off to spend more time on your business
than on my business and how how many
houses i own and how much
exactly are making and all that that's
really not going to help you
if my teaching can help you then learn
and be helped if it can't and you don't
like my teachings then
don't learn and don't be helped but i
don't really feel that i have to put my
tenants
safety and privacy in jeopardy just to
prove something to a skeptic
so that's why that's why not however i
mean jeez the houses that i'm selling at
the moment or the houses i've just sold
oh man you can see those addresses
because they're sold i'm selling um
and i've just sold two flats in morsel
and bridge street i got um
19 rabies street that's selling i can
give you the address that that has
because i'm selling that this this
coming week 19
rabies street in wolverhampton i'm
selling uh
18 maling walk in middlesbrough
i'm selling a hmo little 4-bed hmo in
warmsworth road in doncaster
so i'll give you the addresses once i've
sold them
but but not when they're my houses and
i've got my tenants in there that's just
not happening all right next oh by the
way those houses that i just named as
well
like it's so funny because people have
been saying oh samuel he hasn't got any
properties in his own company
those houses even i just named they're
all owned in my companies as well
in fact one of them is owned in a
company called lucas ruby limited that i
bought off the result of doing my
financial freedom challenge
ping that's that's if that's not saying
something i don't know what isn't so
for those skeptics that said i can't
find samuel's properties on company's
house i know did a whole video about
that
why they're not listed here on these
assets i don't know maybe because
companies house is not the best way to
check properties maybe because companies
house is very
behind the times 18 months at least a
half day i don't know
but you can check the title deeds on
those houses i'm selling and you'll see
that they're owned in my companies
one of them in lucas ruby limited and um
if company's house doesn't acknowledge
it go on land registry and pay three
pound and buy the title did yourself i
don't care and you'll see that my
companies do own properties
and i own a lot of houses as well in my
own personal name which you'll never
find
and i'm not giving the total deeds okay
next um
what properties am i selling i just gave
you the answer
what properties am i selling i mean why
am i selling those particular properties
and not other properties it just depends
on on criteria and circumstances
so the property for instance that i'm
selling in middlesbrough
i've only got one house in middlesbrough
so
if i'm going to be selling some houses
if i've got if i've got like
seven or eight houses in the particular
area like in birmingham i've got quite a
lot of hmos i've got a nice set up there
i've got one management company nice i'm
not going to touch any of them
then if i've got just one house here or
one house there or if one of the
properties is
you know and it also depends on the
tenants some of my tenants
are i was about to sell a house and the
they they contacted me and they said
look we've lived here six years this was
a lease option agreement by the way so
it's not going to be on company's house
all right and own it cash now because i
bought it cash but it was a property
that i bought really cheap because of
the lease option agreement i've done
that this is in blockswitch
my tenants said to me they said
something i know you wanted to sell this
house but the thing is we've lived here
six years we absolutely love it
and we're about to have a baby and we're
literally about to start decorating the
room like is there any chance you cannot
sell it
i said do you want to buy it they said
we can't afford it i said how about rent
to buy i don't mind i'm not i'm not sure
we just want to continue renting and
i've decided not to sell that house
even though i only own two houses in
that particular area i just thought
forget it leave it so
there's lots of different personal and
business reasons as to why i've chosen
the houses to sell that i'm selling
and what the houses but not but i'm not
selling that many houses i've just sold
three i'm about to sell another three
i'm gonna leave it for there all right
but maybe maybe i'll sell another six
next year
i don't know depends on what deal what
other projects i've got going on
uh why the weird predictions
why the weird predictions people have
been going crazy about the predictions
i've been putting out there listen let
me just say this for a start whenever i
put out property predictions
or general predictions i've always been
right up until now now i haven't got a
crystal ball so i can't claim to be a
prophet
but when i predicted the effects of
article 4
it happened section 24 when they first
brought in section 24
2017 they were going to phase into 2020.
everyone's freaking out i just predicted
straight away what's going to happen is
this is not for the first time buyers
this is not for the tenants like george
osborne is saying
this is for the rich and what's going to
happen is it's going to push
actually it's going to push rents up and
people that are buying
and i predicted it and it all happened
and it all came true i predicted
when people were freaking out about
jeremy corbyn and labor potentially
getting in at the time people go oh
what's going to happen what's going to
happen and i predicted that
i said i said to the person that was
going on and on about jeremy corbyn's
going to get in i said listen not only
are labour not going to get in but boris
johnson's going to get in and if jeremy
corbyn gets in
i'll give you 10 000 pounds to put to
your favorite charity it's not gonna
happen so
i'm kind of generally right when i
predict things not necessarily i'm
saying i'm always going to be right but
that's the pattern so far i mean geez
even in 2009
people were saying to me don't buy don't
buy don't buy during the massive crash
what was i doing buying buying buying
i said they're gonna they're gonna pop
back up now i was only a teenager at the
time but i was listening to those that
were smarter than me
and sometimes my predictions are not
even mine sometimes i'll speak to some
of my mentors that are much richer and
smarter than me and i'll ask them
and then i'll form my own opinion and
then i'll put it out there and i'll tell
you what's actually going to happen
because you've got so much nonsense on
social media and
what happened 2009 when i was buying
shut up
so generally i'm right i can't always be
right but generally i'm right so what
was my weird predictions i think i put
it on
instagram and i said this is what i said
was going to happen these were my
predictions
i said for the record here are my
predictions and i posted this
a few weeks back may may the 8th you
will no longer be able to be comfortable
financially but have to choose between
rich or poor as the divide gets a lot
bigger
believe that comfortable people
financially are not going to be
comfortable you're going to have to
choose to be rich or poor which are
going to get richer poor are going to
get poorer
i don't like it but that's just the
reality of it property prices will dip
following trends
virus but in many parts of the north of
england prices will rise still believe
that
still believe that property prices have
gone down generally by i think it was
like a percent and a half last month or
something
um so they're dipping a little bit i
think they're gonna dip actually i think
in about six months they'll
drop but they'll be but not the whole of
the of england not the whole of the uk
some parts will go up
why do i say that because every city
every town has its own economy
you can't just say what a house price is
going to do it depends
depends on the area so
more millionaires will be made than ever
before believe that i believe there's
going to be a lot of millionaires being
made
and and i even since push putting this
out there
just over a month ago that's already
happened i was just on the phone
yesterday to dr john d martini
dr john d martini he's a
multi-millionaire he said he's made more
money during lockdown than ever before
so that's already happening interest
rates will remain
low for years believe that more
legislation will come into the service
accommodation market and it will
increase
the demand believe that hmos will become
more and more popular and rents will
rise rapidly believe that
people saying oh hm no hmo is going to
become more popular it's going to happen
my words and next last prediction
i will have more success students than
ever before and my training company will
expand internationally during these
years of great opportunity
believe believe that one for sure that
one's just gonna happen
so anyway folks i hope you enjoyed this
video i've been very very kind of just
open and personal about things on this
video
uh if you want to know more maybe about
you about how i can help you if you've
got questions about what's going to
happen what you should be investing in
comment your questions below also if you
like this style of video as well
let me know let me know by smashing the
like button let me know by subscribing
and turning the notification bell on
ding and guys thank you so much for
watching thank you massively for those
folks that just
have supported me over the years um i
know there's been a lot of skeptics
there's been a lot of skeptics not just
about me but about property investing in
general
but there was a lot of skeptics in 2009.
property investing is going to be dead
they all said didn't happen
so get ready for the opportunity get
ready to roll your sleeves up work hard
take massive action
but get smart and know what you're doing
thanks so much see you next time
you